To understand a method of means and analysis. Let us look at this blocks
word problem. This is a very famous problem in AI. It has occurred again and
again. And almost every textbook in AI has this problem. You're given a table on
which there are three blocks. And A is on table, B is on table, and
C is on A. This is the initial state. And you want to move these blocks,
to the gold state. On this configuration, so that C is on table, B is on C and
A is on B. The problem looks very simple listen, doesn't it?
Let's introduce a couple of constraints.
You may move only one block at a time, so you can't pick both A and B together.
And second, you may only move a block that has nothing on top of it. So,
you cannot move block A in this configuration, because it has C on top of it.
Let us also suppose that we're given some operators in this world.
These operators essentially move some object to some location. For
example, we could move C to the table, or C onto B, or C onto A.
Not all the operators may be applicable in the current state. C is already on A,
but in principle, all these, all of these operators are available. Given these
operators, and this initial state and this goal state, write a sequence of
operations that will move the blocks from the initial state to the goal state.